hello greetings it's me and edgy Sun
konnichiwa
yokas oh I thought I XI episode
subnautica we're playing subnautica
basically got a lot of really dude you
need to sit down you need to sit down
okay first of all we had a radio message
but we have a lot of cool stuff that I
prepared can you sit sit
are you really gonna sit like that fine
basically now I know how to make I spent
some time playing alone just grinding it
wasn't like I did anything because I'm
supposed to scan everything everyone's
been telling me I know now how to make
where is it see that's the thing I'm
confused by this because I have it here
there I can make it I have the materials
where do I make it I have a gravity trap
now and I have a laser cutter now
cutting device suitable for penetrating
standard time tedium doors okay and we
also have a propulsion cannon which is
basically like the gravity gun in
half-life and I have all of this
organized nicely and I have a chair yes
I sit I didn't know I could sit that's
awesome
you can sit in this game what apparently
if I build a scanner room that will do
the same thing but I'm supposed to build
a beacon I'll just build a scanner room
really quick okay I need to go out and
get some stuff I'll be a minute gamers
Oh God oh rich Stimpy's gamers look I
have this now so if I want to grab that
thing come here come here quick wink
wink wink me mine I don't have to touch
any of the yucky stuff you know okay
these are the ones I need can I use this
whoa well we can shoot it she says no I
just want it I thought for some reason I
didn't need my knife silly of me huh
so can I shoot this guy away nope
the answer's no see I thought I prepared
for this episode clearly I did not come
here
yeah oh no he missed him how I just need
the copper
I wish the game had a little bit more of
this this like nice comfy arias like a
lot of them are just really scary yes
Jesus Christ
the timings I have in these games are
just perfect aren't they say I think my
bass is here somewhere what up fatty J
bulimics me batty bear alright where do
I build this there really really really
there there
alright we're building it alright we're
building it here it's glorious look at
it wow my scan the room that looks so
good and that's a camera dude so now
that shows up cool that's literally the
only reason I did that bye yes now the
second mystery of this playthrough which
is how in the bloody name do I build the
thing I need a moon pool alright I hate
to disappoint you guys but I can't build
it yet dammit
alright well let's go check out the
signal then it's only 800 meters down
that's not that deep right that's really
a leash level of deep let's get real
here I don't like going deep
that's what your mom said thank you
YouTube comments
nothing steeper than me sir we can't go
any deeper okay I think I think we hit
the top of it alright so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna change battery and then
we're gonna go three two one go
ooh spooky Snooki oh god what the hell
is that fart noises fart noises open
abandon PDA is that it I gotta go back
up back up gamers I've read through
straw
okay so cool we can see our camera now
wait we have repulsion cannon now use
the propulsion cannon and a computer
chip I don't know if I can make a
computer I can okay all right we can
make that I'm swimming away Satan open
course for the virgin sea god damn this
is spooky swimming by Taylor sweet what
the hell was that
I've been there yes I'm so scared a pee
myself but nobody notices
home sweet home alabama' friend's son
would be proud
danke freakish and computer-chip dun dun
boom boom we have that look how neatly
organized look how easy this game is I
practically beaten the game already
let's get real here gamers let's stop
beating around the bush I got a freaking
propulsion cannon that is not what I
wanted to make is that I just made the
same cannon didn't I I'm a [ __ ] idiot
are you kidding me edit that out edit
that out
edit that out right now
I wanted to make the repulsion you idiot
I just needed a magnet goddamn it
oh my god my brain is so small why did
no one tell me my brain is so small okay
turns out I can't do anything because
I'm an idiot it's anyone surprised I'm
not what do i do then I thought I was so
prepared let's go to the island I think
it's in the Northeast damn this place is
cool I'm not going there I changed my
mind I changed my mind guys for some
reason don't feel like going there I
don't care how pretty it is oh here we
go
found something ooh
two out of three baby yes okay we can
make the mobile vehicle Bay at least
it's something there it is it's being
made as we speak gamers so how is that
better and then what I already have been
guess we'll have to see a mentor it's
full
all right gamers so let's try this out
okay all right I like this how do I get
on me I keep falling outfit oh it's on
the surface oh what a mess oh oh okay
okay okay okay we can make it now good
news after all all right let's check the
message and then we can well that's far
away it's time to build freakin my
submarine I call Seema it's nice and
it's so clean look at it bill right in
front of me a drop in water it's pledge
please straight from the deck this is
flipping dipping finger licking teddy
squishing awesome can I use these items
while I'm in there we live in a suburb
can drain out oops sorry about that
gamers could be anybody booth what it's
that bad it's that bad you're that bad
well then what's the point if I can only
go 200 meters
huh how do we stop it I just kill the
fish probably sorry I got windshield
wipers it's all good
you're not so shoot no no no no no about
not flipping cool day all right well
let's go to or what is it there
ah there's do what is it me or do I see
better that's not I feel like I see
better sorry sorry I'm sorry I don't
want this to break that would be a great
tragedy I need to shape up cuz I need a
man stop it you're hurting me flipper
jump yeah we can go 200 meters deep and
then use that as a base
they say I'm a great pilot they were
absolutely dead wrong so we can go to
Ana meters deep so Bing Bing Bing Bing
Bing Bing all right so I think we have
to go through ppl it's a little scary
it's a little scary but we'll do this
we'll do this all right yeah you gave us
ready for gamer moon of the decade
gaming moment of the decade ain't afraid
ain't afraid ain't afraid
ain't afraid what does this it's a
second thing
I can't use it all right abort abort
abort i snort you know you think it's
submarine could go you know deep cringe
oh wow it's not how we look like
Barbara Barbara Barbara Barbara Barbara
Barbara Barbara back maybe the baby
remove I would have a skinny move
skipping a poo skipping a poopy poop
skip any poop with a poof oh yeah
new blueprint the blueprint I pick up
some lemon lemon my dick isn't a Flint
made of Flint sharp as Flint yeah yeah
yeah what is this I remember very
distinctly I don't have many memories
from my childhood but I do remember very
distinctly having a play-doh mobile
helicopter and the sound I would make
with that I remember so clearly I would
make that's how an helicopter sound like
I would do that as I flew with it that's
that's about it so much fun you can have
us a Swedish boy growing up I never been
here it's a pretty cool place why what I
hear ah stupid fish yes all right we
better go back and repair now just wait
till I get lasers on there damn it damn
it
stupid fish they're everywhere I think
we should go to the island
it's a pokémon's Oh
oh did you oh oh I got the shivers no
we're gonna go there I think I'll go
this way
my eyes have been open god I'm terrified
dude legit like the thing is so scary
what are these Kabuto looking mother
effers alright maybe now we can ex quiet
oh look at that gamers yeah
the one who seeks shall find Oh what was
that is he following me what in the
world is that dude ah this is where I
once tried to go before and failed
miserably so as well whoa
I think these connect to the ones where
I all we found another one what do I do
with these keep finding them I'm getting
good at staring this I take that back I
guess I beat the game like I've done
then I done everything could this be
something moonpool I think that's
important I think yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes gosh the game just changed
completely now I love it so good it's
got to be good knowing you're watching
the absolute most best gamer over the
world as well playing this the best game
ever in the world after minecraft of
course of course alright in this park
our car and let's see what this is all
about so I only had the blueprint I
don't know what it takes to come
none I'm gonna end that episode there
hope you guys enjoyed this epic episode
smash like to support the series and I
see you guys in the next episode thanks
for the support
hey do you know what big peepees do they
play PewDiePie pixel ings of course
pixel ings is a creature collecting game
I'm the primary shareholder over a
brazilian players have downloaded and
it's got a perfect score it's safe to
say it's the most popular game of all
time
PewDiePie pixel aims it's awesome deal
with it deal with
[Music]